فيديو نشرته وكاله ناسا لاول مره يلاحظ
فيه ثلاث نقاط تتحرك
ذهابا وايابا لما كان يعتقد انها اجسام
طائره مجهوله التقط الفيديو طيار كان في
مهمه تدريبيه في غرب الولايات المتحده
ولكن عند التعمق اكثر ومراجعه بيانات
مراقبه الحركه الجويه تبين للخبراء ان تلك
الاجسام لم تكن سوى طائرات تجاريه متجهه
الى مطار رئيسي للهبوط وكانت ابعد بكثير
مما كان متصورا في البدايه مثال لما يمكن
ان يخدع اجهزه الاستشعار او يقدم تصورا
خاطئا للبعض حتى لو كانوا طيارين مدربين
تدريبا عاليا
لطالما ارتبطت الظواهر مجهوله الهويه
والمعروفه باسم الاجسام الطائره
بالخيال والغموض و في الافلام السينمائيه
وحكت عنها سيناريوهات مرتبطه بمؤامرات
سياسيه لذلك اخذت لجنه المكلفه من وكاله
ناسا على عاتقها مهمه اعداد خريطه طريق
لتفسير تلك الظواهر علميا وتخطط لتقديم
تقرير نهائي في اواخر شهر يوليو المقبل
لفهم تلك الاجسام بشكل افضل لابد من جمع
البيانات المستهدفه وتنظيمها وتحليلها
بشكل شامل سيساعد هذا النهج على تمييز
مشاهدات الاجسام الطائره المجهوله عن
غيرها من المشاهدات غير المبرره وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه البنتاجون كانت اجرت
جهدا لتحليل مشاهدات الاجسام الطائره
المجهوله
وتدفق اليها الكثير من التقارير بعد ان
تبنت سياسه تشجيع على التحدث عندما يرون
اشياء غريبه وفحص البانتاجون اكثر من 800
مشاهده بناء على المعلومات التي جمعت على
مدار ما يقرب من ثلاثه عقود من بين تلك
المشاهدات حدد ما بين اثنين وخمسه في
المئه فقط من تلك الاجسام انها شاذه او لا
يمكن تفسيرها تجري لجنه ناسا تحقيقها بشكل
منفصل عن جهود البانتوجون لكنها تفتقر حتى
الان الى البيانات الكافيه للمساعده في
وصف تلك التقارير المرتبطه بالاجسام
الطائره المجهوله وتحتاج الى جمع بيانات
وتنظيمها بشكل شامل
وتحليلها في كل الاحوال تقول ناسا انه لا
يوجد دليل على ان الاجسام الطائره الغريبه
التي ابلغ الناس عنها منسوبه لذكاء خارج
كوكب الارض ويعد تقريرها المنتظر مهما
لتبديد ولو بعض الغموض حول المشاهد التي
لم تفسر من قبل وفصل الحقيقه عن الخيال